اهلا بكم في هذا الموجز اعلنتر يا ست
السويديه للاتحاد الاوروبي وزراء خارجيه
الاتحاد اقر وحزمه جديده من العقوبات على
ايران واضافت في تغريده ان العقوبات
تستهدف من يقودون القمع ضد المتظاهرين
السلميين على حد تعبيرها
هذا وقال بيان للاتحاد الاوروبي الجديده
ضد الافراد والكيانات الايرانيه تشمل
تجميد الاصول وحضر سفر الى دول الاتحاد
وحضرات الاموال لمن هم مدرجون في القائمه
وقد تفاد القرار الحرس الثوري في غياب
قرار قضائي
اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبه شملت
المؤسسه التعاونيه للحرس الثوري الايراني
و خمسه اعضاء من مجلس ادارتها ونائب وزير
الاستخبارات والامنه و 4 من كبار قاده
الحرس الثوري في ايران هذا واقله الوزاره
ان العقوبات تستهدف ركيزه اقتصاديه رئيسيه
للحرس الثوري الايراني معتبره انها تموره
من القمع الوحشي على حد تعذير البيان
دعوه وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امين
عبد اللاهين الدول الاوروبيه كافه
للابتعاد عما وصفها بمواقف غير بناء وغير
منطقيه والا تتخذ خطوات يمكن ان تكون لها
فداعيه جسيمه وفق تعبيره واضاف للوزير
الايراني في تصريح له انه في حاله اتخاذ
الدول الاوروبيه قرارا ضد مؤسسه سياديه
مثل الحرس الثوري فستشهد ردا قويا ومؤثرا
من جانب طهران حسب قوله
هلا مساله سياسيه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي لانه زار التوصل الى اتفاق
سياسيا على تقديم حزمه سابعه من المساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا
وقالت وزيره الخارجيه البلجيكيه انبلجيكا
جمدت اصولا روسيه ضخمه واضافت في مقابله
مع الجزيره ان استخدامها هذه الاصول في
اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا يحتاج الى اطار
قانوني وهو ما لا يتوفر حتى اللحظه
تبادلت روسيا واستونيا طرد السفراء وتخفيض
التمثيل الدبلوماسيه وافادت وكاله تاسه
الروسيه ان الخارجيه الاسطانيه طلبت من
السفير الروسي لديها مغادره البلاد
بالتزامن مع مغادره السفير الاستوني
لروسيا
قرر المحقق العدلي في قضيه انفجار مرفا
بيروت استئناف تحقيقاته في ملف الانفجار
كما قرر اخلاء سبيل خمسه موقفين والدعاء
على ثمانيه اشخاص بينهم مسؤولين امنيان
رفع المستوى وقد اعلن وزير العدل في حكومه
تصريف الاعمال احاله القراريل مجلس القضاء
الاعلى
نظم اعضاء في حزب اللكود ومستوطنون واعضاء
منظمته يهوديه متشدده تجمع عندنا مشاري في
تجمع الخان الاحمر شرقي القدس وايات هذا
الحشد في اطار الضغوط التي تمارس على
حكومه نتنياهو لكي تسرع في تنفيذ قرار هدم
التجمع وازاله وفقا لمنظم الحشد وقد حذر
مفاوض سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
من خطوره الوطن
[موسيقى]